my name is Chris Peterson I'm half
Danish half German I'm born and I grew
up in Frankfort mine then I live 20
years in Berlin before I moved to Poland
five years ago here I live and work as
freelance gastronome as kitchen chef and
as culinary tour guide over an
international hosting website
I had visitors from Poznan in Poland
seven years ago which became very good
friends of mine on my first visit to
Poland I was overwhelmed by the strong
cultural and economic development that
is going on here
I was very interested in local and
regional food products from colleagues
and I started visiting farms and
producers in the area on one of these
tours I realized that hardly anyone in
other countries know about the great
quality and variety of Polish food the
idea of guiding culinary tours in Poland
was born
it is so nice to be in a country where
you see development and people's
motivation and courage to do something
new life here in Bozeman in such a
beautiful part of the European Union is
truly great